le président de connections productions
vient de déménager en nouvelle écosse
parce que le nouveau brunswick a décidé
de suspendre son programme de
financement à l'industrie du film et de
la télévision
le temps de mener une révision depuis le
mois de janvier je suis néo écossais
mais françois savoie vite à nouveau dans
l'incertitude depuis le dépôt du budget
ça tue si le premier jeu nouveau la
nouvelle-écosse reste avec ce qu'il
propose dans tous homos l'europe et
d'industrie la province a annoncé une
réduction de 75% du crédit d'impôt
remboursable pour les productions
cinématographiques une économie de 18
millions de dollars par année pour le
gouvernement
la vraie coupure ça va être très de 400
à 425 on va faire de quelques de toutes
les retombées plus le dommage culturel
touristique et l'image compte qu'on
projet on ne veut pas de jeunes on ne
veut pas de culture on veut on ne veut
pas être agressif en série dramatique
environ 2000 personnes travaillent dans
l'industrie du cinéma en nouvelle écosse
la décision du gouvernement soulève un
tollé
working to on est ouverts à trouver une
solution affirme la ministre qui précise
ne pas avoir l'argent nécessaire pour
maintenir le système actuel les
travailleurs de l'industrie du film et
de la télévision crois que plus la
nouvelle écosse tarder à rétablir un
financement adéquat plus elle risque de
perdre sa réputation de terre d'accueil
pour le cinéma
au fil des ans la nouvelle écosse a
accueilli de grandes productions comme
titanic k 19 le piège des profondeurs et
la lettre écarlate game has been done
selon ce porte-parole de l'industrie des
projets ont déjà été perdus et des
travailleurs ont quitté la province
une situation qui risque de s'aggraver
si une entente n'est pas conclue
rapidement ici marilyn marceau radio
canada à halifax